I was like oh so we going dancing she
was like no we're not going dancing I go
what are you doing she goes well we're
not leaving the
van this is about the worst thing I've
ever watched I'm reacting to my dad's
standup story about the first time he
had sex with a grown woman gross let's
see how loud this is guys young guys who
have fantasies about
mils I want to tell you something right
now you're not ready I'm not ready
and neither is your wife or your other
kids ready to hear this I used to work
at Dick's Last Resort on the river okay
and um I had a woman come that's how old
he is he used to work down by the river
I was um bartending and um she comes in
with her three friends and it was like a
Saturday afternoon and we were just kind
of all flirting a little bit and then
her two friends left and she stayed she
mid-30s probably and so I had only
talked to like yo young women I was like
oh your friendss uh your friends left
you
alone not how you should approach a
woman this was right when I knew I was
in trouble I go you stay by yourself I'm
trying to be you know Flex guy I go you
stay by yourself I go aren't you a
little scared to be here by yourself and
she goes no but you should
be you know I had a little movement
right when she said that I'm like boing
yeah I am that's an assertive woman I
feel like I'd have been scared just from
that like he says movement I
see and she slid piece of paper over
nobody ever talked to me like this
before she slid a piece of paper over
and she goes write your address down I'm
picking you up tonight we're going
out and I was like oh yeah
okay living with two other dudes who are
around 20 21 years old and um my I walk
in I'm super happy and my buddy goes why
are you so happy what are you doing he
goes you get plants tonight I go yeah he
goes what are you going to do I go I'm
GNA [__] a
grown-up I mean okay look if a buddy
told me that I'd be like [__] yeah but
if my dad told me that I'd be like
absolutely
not because at 21 you're mid-30s you're
a [__] grownup I was like she
probably does dishes and goes to the
store and
[__] [__] great if dishes going to
the store our grownup thing I've been a
grown-up since I was like 17 what are we
talking about I didn't know what
grown-ups wore on dates and my college
wardrobe was pretty limited so I just I
would I I must have changed clothes like
this is this what a grown-up
was and so finally she pulls into the
driveway in a
minivan now it makes sense as to why you
drove us around in a minivan for so many
years you trying to relive The Glory
Days old
man and my buddy looks out the window
and he goes hey
wolf your mom's
here got to say as your son watching
this one hits a little different because
if things were unprotected that night
she could have been my mom I hop into
her van
right and um I I'm sitting in the front
seat and I've been practicing like I
think like what grown-ups say to each
other you know so I just sat there and I
I put on my seat belt I go so um do you
want to go to dinner tonight she goes no
we're not going to dinner so then I
thought she was like one I know what
that means I guess it's more prominent
in my generation we'll just call it a
car date okay so I was like oh so we
going dancing she was like no we're not
going dancing I go what are you doing
she goes we're not leaving the
van
she goes you know where Breen Ridge Park
is I go yeah she goes we're going to go
[__] in the park and I'm
like but I will tell you this we're
we're dudes like 25 and under anybody in
here 25 and
under
yeah listen guys young guys who have
fantasies about
mils I want to tell you something right
now you're not ready
you're not ready cuz a grown woman knows
what she wants you are
not that woman in the audience would
like you Josh Wolf and you're going to
need to get off stage real
[Applause]
fast yeah if there's a dude sitting next
to that girl you're doing something
wrong just so you
know she was like like
yes but here's the deal as a young man
because women in their 30s will say this
to you as a young man you're not ready
for someone who you're having sex with
who you think you're doing what you're
putting it down you're not ready for
someone to look at you and go what the
[__] are you
doing I'm doing my this is my move no it
isn't don't do that why are you doing
that that's terrible you're not ready
for that we pull into the parking lot
and she looks at me and we park the car
she looks at me she goes help me put the
car seats in the
back I was
right I was [__] right the car seats
were still in the car oh and I was
plural I was right she was like I'm not
wasting any time you kids get the [__]
out of the car I'll move your seats
later like Mommy's going on a date she
just left that [__] in her car so we got
out of the car and we [__] put the
car seats in the way back right here
were Cheerios and yoohoo [__] all over
the [__] that's a mid [__] snack
you're a folk in a grown woman's car
there's going to be snacks we start to
roll around and I'm going tell you I
wasn't a really experienced dude um even
in college especially that I still look
I'm not going to lie to you it took me
to around 23 24 to really get used to
the fact that the vagina was so far
back I remember even at like 20 I was
bouncing around here like what why what
is the like did you not have a health
class or like anatomy class in the 60s
what's you were born in the 60s the
1860s do your research come on do I need
a code or something like is it going to
pop open for me or is there a password I
need for this area the dick is here the
vagina should be there nope it's I
wasn't used to how close it was was to
the [__] like I was like so I guess
she got tired of me messing around with
the mound area for as long as I did and
she you did not call it a mound
area oh my God another another thing not
to do gentlemen this is a big video of
things not to do when getting in bed
with a woman presented by Josh Wolf he
just slapped my hand
she goes here's what I want you to do
she goes I want you to lay down on the
ground I had [__] Cheerios stuck to
my back and
[__] and she gets on top of me and I go
to grab her hips and she goes and don't
touch
me I said what do you want me to do she
said and don't talk
[Applause]
either she just said to me she looked me
dead in the eye and she goes all you
have to do is not [__] this up for
me
this woman sounds scary and
then I felt like a scratching post of
some
kind
like I had I had I had rug burn this is
back when people had rugs you
know this
is but it was like I was like I'm
irritated on the belly
area yo she wrote that it was like a she
did the full 8 seconds dude [__]
wo and her Dismount was like it was O
like an Olympic
gymnast and then but I just it's the
first time in my life like so many
things happened like she she laughed she
slapped me she cried like I was like
what's happening right now I had no idea
it's the first time I had ever been
[__] you
know and based on your experience of
talking about it I think it was the last
time you were [__] as well so yeah I
feel
like this doesn't sound like a
pleasurable experience to me like this
sounds borderline painful
honestly dude I she hopped off me I was
just like well do I at least get an
orange slice and a Capri
[Applause]
on that is ridiculous tips from Josh
Wolf we learned today one mils may not
be the fantasy you are looking for and
two if they are bring protection and I'm
not talking about a condom I'm talking
about head gear good luck everybody